good morning john australia is a pretty
isolated place geographically but then
isolated significantly from australia we
have the islands of new zealand but then
we go deeper and there are a number of
islands isolated off the north coast of
the south island of new zealand and
all the way at the tip of them that's
where we find
takapurewa or stevens island isolated
from the isolated a kind of ecological
experiment that the earth accidentally
designed
takapurewa is home to a number of
different
very weird species including this weevil
that makes no sense what might be the
rarest frog in the world
literally millions of seabirds something
called the darkling beetle and of course
it is a stronghold of tuatara but the
weirdest of them in my opinion is the
one
that no longer exists lyle's wren was a
weird bird it was a passerine the
largest order of birds more than half of
all bird species are passings you can
distinguish them from other birds
because they have
three toes in the front and one in the
back good for grabbing onto sticks and
perching
but it was unlike any still-existing
passerine because it could not
fly like the whole point of being a
little bird is flying right
lyle's wren basically filled the
ecological niche of a small rodent
because there were no small rodents on
new zealand it ran around really fast
and had lots of babies and ate insects
and worms and fruits and stuff but if
you're gonna be a mouse
you're gonna be worse at it if you only
have two legs and so when polynesian
rats were introduced to new zealand by
the maori
they both out-competed and just consumed
lyle's wrench but polynesian rats
never got to takapura but then
cat now there's an urban legend that
lyle's wren was actually extincted by
one single cat this isn't exactly what
happened we're not 100 sure
how cats got to the island we think
probably the lighthouse keepers
brought them there because they were
lonely but at some point a cat or
several cats arrived at the island and
the name assigned to the cat that in the
urban legend killed off the lyles ran
was tibbles and i really like that name
i don't know where it came from
it may very well have been david lyle's
cast so let's just say that david lyle
one of the lighthouse keepers
had a relationship that was deep enough
with a cat that sometimes that cat
brought him
presents as cats do and one time that
present was a dead bird
that was unknown to science and that is
how lyle got credit for discovering
lyles wren
it should be called tibbles as ren thank
you very much
it should actually be called tibbles a
camphisitid because
it's not even a wren by the time tibbles
showed up with that bird there was
already a large and thriving population
of feral cats on the island the space
between lyle being given that gift and
the probable extinction of the species
was barely more than a year
extinction sucks but the good news is
that there are now
no longer any cats on takapura there
aren't even any people there anymore the
lighthouse is operated remotely and the
only reason people go there is to study
this
marvelous natural experiment that earth
created for us that experiment
goes on one bird down for sure and with
a lot of ecological degradation but it
goes on
and with a marvelous ecology nonetheless
john
is now 25 days left until july 7th when
the carl saga concludes
and a beautifully foolish endeavor is
released which means i have some things
to talk about first you can pre-order
signed editions of a beautifully foolish
endeavor
all over the place including now at
waterstones in the uk second i'm doing a
penguin world's book club event for the
first book an absolutely remarkable
thing with cat valenti who is amazing
third john you and i are going to be
doing a launch event on july 7th
at 7 00 p.m eastern that will be here
that will be available to everyone we're
gonna have a good old time
fourth there will be a book tour it will
be all digital bright side
that means everyone can come stick it at
events include july 6th with john july
8th with ashley ford july 9th with roman
mars
and july 10th with corey doctor so you
get to pick your special guest and all
these are in partnership with local
bookstores around the country everybody
who buys a ticket gets a signed copy of
the book in the mail the first 500
people who sign up at each place get a
lapel pin
that you cannot get any other way it's
gonna be fun and weird and you can find
out more information at the links in the
description john
i'll see you on tuesday